what's your comedians be looking for in
an agent or any red flags
you know I think I mean for me because I
was a buyer first when I produced Shaq
all-star mm-hmm I dealt with agents and
so my experience with the big guys that
had you know most of you know the people
that were on Shaq all-star is that they
wouldn't tell the truth or they would
you know use one you know one person's
offer to leverage another person's offer
when they're two separate people or they
would lag they they know full well that
they weren't going to do it and they
wouldn't give me the courtesy of telling
me that it was a pass or you know just
just you know just really being
underhanded or if something went wrong
being cowardly and not being able to say
something went wrong to allow the buyer
to have time to recover because it's
show business right thing things change
all the time and so that's the constant
is change but when you're when you don't
have the information to recover it puts
you in a bad situation
so everything that really perturbed me
about agents I don't do you know it's
like I try to get I don't you know I
don't avoid calls so there's not gonna
be a time when somebody calls my office
and I keep saying
tell me call back telling the car I'm
not putting my assistant in that
situation I take the call and let's
resolve it and so I can get it off my
desk and that they're not if it's no
it's no you know so I think you know
making sure that the agents not blowing
smoke hmm that they're really you know
if they can't do so I would prefer for
work you know I prefer for someone to
tell you the truth so you know how to
recover from that
then for somebody to say oh no it's
gonna be you know just you know give it
two months you'll be living in LA you'll
be you know all that and you're
preparing for something that may not be
your truth so I would say look for
somebody that can tell you the good and
the bad and you know isn't afraid to
give you the criticism
that you need to grow and on the
management side I guess it's only agents
here at innovative so the manager
they're more of like you said the
strategy because this is a world I'm
unfamiliar whether I'm unwrapped and
just been doing everything independently
so the manager what are the kind of
skills that they would bring to the
table I mean they would lay out the
strategy for you and say okay what are
the projects that you have what are your
goals and then let's map out how you get
there and then they use the agency to
put that you know to make those things
come true whether that's calls or
meetings and Matt there's a lot there's
some definitely some overlap especially
in the beginning of somebody doesn't
have an agent and then in my case I have
some guys that have been in the business
a long time
they don't have managers so then I end
up as a hybrid which because I've been
on the other side of the business I can
do but it's time-consuming so in a
perfect world you have some a manager
that is working hand in hand with you
and you know so I don't have to stop and
go find the assets that I need to show
that this person is amazing mm-hmm you
know but the but then managers to
managers can produce so they can be
partners with the client in terms of you
know putting I guess it come together
agents can't agents can only Commission
and it's a like I said a real
transactional relationship
mm-hm so managers aren't supposed to
book there's so there's like you know
there's like rules to it really that a
lot of people outside of LA don't adhere
to out of necessity more so out of you
know just hustling what you get but once
you get here there's an etiquette you
know that it's nice if it's followed and
more embraced and nobody knows what's
embraced and comedy more than you with
your experience and the people you've
been around you've you work with the
like one percent of comedy so being
around these exclusively like
high-performing high achieving people
what are some of the common traits
you're seeing with these people
[Music]
I breath